quite seriously um
you are one of the
i mean strongest athletes in the world
for your sport
so you have to get big you have to get
powerful you have to get strong
what is the right diet for you for that
like
what do you eat
how often do you eat
um
yeah from the the highest detail to the
smallest or the things that make you
happy and feel good yeah
i've experimented with every diet i've
done it all i've been a vegan uh i've
done raw
i've eaten only meat
i've eaten balanced
eaten like a bodybuilder
you know
you name it i've probably tried it
um
i don't believe that it was important in
the sport of arm wrestling as it is
perhaps in other sports
uh i believe that
i mean just to be very basic i mean if
you're eating enough food you're
probably gonna be okay um
so it's just calories it's a lot i mean
it really i mean not to over complicate
it but i mean that's that's where the
conversation starts are you eating
enough food um
and it can come in any number of ways
and
i i i don't think it's as important
as a lot of other people do
i'm certainly irresponsible in a lot but
the thing is
back to like volume right like you need
to like if if you want to be a super
heavyweight yeah
it's very different than if you want to
be a weight category guy yeah if you
want to be a weight category guy i'd say
that you need to be more responsible
make better choices
if you want to be a super heavyweight
everything
just so we're watching a delicious
looking omelette so eggs bacon
syrup so you don't care carbs approach
so you know all the things you try so i
mostly eat
meat now yeah and i landed on that
there's several
things you know obviously i'm not
but i do a lot of sport yeah and i was
very surprised how my particular very
specific body can perform
uh better with only me
why better the sports i do the mind
matters and so for some reason my mind
is just clear yeah and i i don't think
because it feels unhealthy it just makes
me feel really good i don't think i
would recommend it to anybody else
so
it's
it's interesting that that journey
of just exploring can take you to figure
out something about your own self
one of the most interesting things that
i heard about nutrition
was
i heard there was actually doritos yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm an idiot
uh
now i do i'd say over the last couple
years i've really gone into the into
carbs a lot and high glycemic carbs and
you know just to i feel like it's one of
the best things you can do if you're
working out really hard just cheers add
carbs
exactly
um
but
oh where was i
so good so you've had
distracted
no so you've added the high glycemic
carbs into the mix so that you those
help but that's for mass building right
so
there was a study that i heard about by
somebody who's trying to identify heart
attacks they did this great big study
and at the end of it i mean didn't
matter what the people ate
the the most important thing was how
they felt about the food that they were
eating
yeah
so if you believe in the food if you
believe that it's going to do good
things for you and if you allocate it
the right way it's it's going to have a
positive impact
and i try and do that no matter what it
is like i have my foods that i think do
certain things
and so
you know for me i know that
actually i mean i learned about corn fed
pumps when i was overseas
uh i realized that if i i never used to
eat crap really didn't i ate super clean
all the time
and
when i was faced with imminent death
more
i would be like okay i'm going out
tonight let's have let's have a couple
ice cream bars
you know like whatever
and
what i realized is
if i eat like an entire bag of chips or
like you know a bunch of chocolate bars
and then i go and have a workout
my workout will be incredible
it'll be incredible
um
there's something about
easily processed carbohydrate
that will continue to quickly
get into your blood
as fast as you can burn it
and
there's something about that that uh
well gives you incredible blood blood
flow
yeah and also your mind plugging in
enjoying that right
and then believing it works and that's
how it makes it work better exactly i
mean i i feel that way i think this is
really not
this has been frustrating to me about
the health culture in the united states
in the studies
that are done you know you look at like
the importance of sleep the importance
of x diet
all those kinds of things i i wish
incorporated into that would be
your mental relationship with all of
these things so for example people that
tell me well your sleep schedule is
insane
yes
perhaps
but also
it's insane because i'm doing what i
love and i don't see it as a problem
right and i
i think that's really important to
understand if if you if you're
if you sleeping crazy hours uh
is not affecting your stress and it's
actually making you happy or you're
drawing some kind of source of
happiness and pleasure and satisfaction
like being awake when others aren't it's
like the
mike tyson thing or something like
training when you you've convinced
yourself everybody's sleeping and
therefore you're somehow training much
better right that's powerful even if you
look statistically
six hours maybe worse than eight hours
or four hours maybe worse than six hours
so the mind is a powerful thing super
powerful
but if you want to be a super
heavyweight eat
you got to eat like stupid amounts all
the time yeah you have to test your
digestive system what's your favorite
meal by the way just if you had to you
know ah i am
uh i do oh geez i like so much food
that's tough but i'd say the food that i
rely on a lot when i'm uh getting ready
to compete is sushi just because it
normally comes in an all you can eat
format
you know
so you know i love to go and just binge
all you can eat just all you can eat
buffets sushi is just super convenient
you